[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down John
Wick 4. the film is packed with a number
of different Easter eggs in details and
this scene by scene breakdown is gonna
be going over it all
[Music]
although you could easily think this
movie picks up right after John Wick 3.
there's actually somewhat of a time Jump
between this film and the last one the
directed chats to helski stayed in
interviews that the movie happens about
eight months after the prior film and we
can see this passage of time and some of
the characters and locations Wick fell
off the Continental at the end of
chapter 3 but his wounds are now healed
and we see this in the case of the
Bowery King as well the scarsy suffered
for betraying the high table have healed
up and New York itself also indicates
the passage of time as well chapter 1 2
and 3 happen pretty much back to back
with them all taking place roughly
during the Spring in this film though
New Yorkers covered in snow and we also
know that the Elder has been replaced
this is an important Motif as it shows
Jon that all the members are themselves
operating like a Hydra Hercules had his
Hydra you have the table except you'll
run out of bullets before they run out
of heads if you get rid of one then one
will just come back and fill that place
and he hasn't got enough bullets to take
down the entire assassin world that very
much plays in the ending of the movie
and his plan to help Kane finally leave
the life behind now the pair have a big
conversation in the church at one point
and collider pointed out this is a
reference to John Woo's movie The Killer
centering around a policeman chasing a
Hitman we see two people on the opposite
sides of the track clashing throughout
the film now John ended up turning his
back on the Hitman universe and this was
so could go and have a life with the
woman he loved Kane wished to be with
his daughter and he is sort of a dark
mirror of Jon in the end Wick saves him
by letting him finally leave the life to
be with his loved one which is a fate
that he himself got to experience when
he stepped away this happens during a
big duel and I love how they have to
remove their jackets in order to do this
because we see that they're complete
bullet sponges
thank you
[Music]
now Escaping The Life enabled Jon to
have a few short years with his wife in
which he experienced genuine freedom and
happiness that's what he wants for Kane
too and it's why he realizes that he has
to be smart when taking down the high
table the entire film is about death and
Legacy and though Jon had the reputation
of being a cold-blooded killer we see in
the end how he truly wished to be
remembered his final words are his
wife's name and his gravestone has the
phrase loving husband embossed into it
he also dies lying back on the stairs
which Chad state was a direct reference
to one of his favorite animes that is
Cowboy Bebop and interestingly Keanu was
also considered a place by Spiegel at
one point but we all know how that
turned out with Netflix getting the
rights to it
now when talking about the film The
Creative team said that they were
inspired by the hagakua and how one must
be accepting of their death just like
how jonus the original title for chapter
4 was gonna be John Wick hagakura but
they changed this to being Baba Yaga in
some territories like Baba Yaga
we have done a big breakdown for the
alternate ending of the film and
originally Lionsgate wanted the dog to
look over at the graveyard and see John
standing there that was of course cut
but some of the lines of dialogue do
remain with both the Bowery King and
Winston saying that he's neither in
heaven or hell this would continue the
motif that he managed to escape by
faking his death which actually has some
symbolism when we get to that big stair
scene we'll talk about that later on and
in the end the team felt like this
should be the final chapter and this his
death is a conclusive one in the end
unless Hollywood brings him back because
they always bring him back looking at
you fast actually either way we begin by
joining join as he's smashing a post
like it's a like button and I remember
watching this in IMAX in the cinema and
it was legitimately shaking my entire
chair
the Barry King then rattles up his
speech and we hear the words
these are taken directly from Dante's
Inferno which I feel like I mentioned in
every video to the point it's becoming a
catchphrase however there is a reason
that work's been adapted so many times
into film and it very much acts as a
metaphor for the journey that John goes
on throughout the film he travels
through the nine circles of hell and
this is a story that's appeared in the
franchise before if we go back to John
Wick 3 The Hitman Earnest also pulled
from the book during the opening scene
now there's a ton of biblical imagery in
the film and John of course dies at the
end of the movie with the church behind
him the opening scene is actually also
shot in a sunken Parisian cathedral
which is known as La defense and
throughout the film John can also be
seen as the personification of death in
the opening we watch as he rides on a
black horse alongside three others and
these represent the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse Kane kills his quote-unquote
brother and no price for guessing that
this is riffing on Kane and Abel now
beyond that Lauren's fish bin and Keanu
are teaming up again in this franchise
which of course reunites the pair from
The Matrix movies that relationship is
somewhat reflected in this movie as
Morpheus acted as somewhat of a guy to
Neo as he reached the Hidden World and
navigated through the underworld that's
what the Bowery King does too and it's
something that they referenced in the
behind the scenes stuff now the Barry
King Sparks up a match which creates a
fire and symbolically this shows the
path of Destruction that he's about to
go on beyond that though we follow it
with a clear note to Lawrence of Arabia
and the infamous match cut that they do
in that film
foreign
take us to the desert and if we're
getting super meta we have a character
played by an actor named Lawrence
referencing a movie about a character
called Lawrence
now where John ends up in the desert
it's also a location they shut up for
Lawrence of Arabia and the elders
designed no traditional could be a nod
to Alec Guinness's Prince Faisal anyway
in both scenes he watches the sunrise is
and this mirrors the ending of the movie
in which the sun rises as Jon passes
away metaphorically sunrises show the
beginning of a new journey and John's
starting one here and then another at
the end when he goes on to the next life
now the killing starts almost instantly
and according to IMDb nicest guy in
Hollywood Keanu Reeves gifted each stunt
worker with a personalized t-shirt
detailing how many times that performer
met Adam is in the film his five-person
stunt team also received Rolex
Submariner watches each costing around
ten thousand dollars with a personalized
message on the back bloody nice guy and
speaking of jewelry Wickers returned to
get his wedding ring back and we saw in
the prior movie how he had it removed as
part of The Pact with the high table
this symbolized that he was is married
to them and would serve the organization
forever instead of finding an attachment
to a specific person a missing thing is
something we also see Clancy Brown's
harboring a sporting and Kane of course
gave her the size too later on with
nobody he admits to doing this
voluntarily and you might be wondering
what he means when he says this they
didn't take them
I gave them well I I think McCain wanted
to create a way where he didn't think
that he'd ever be called back after all
who would hire a blind Hitman well me
because the guys like Daredevil
now John of course went back on the deal
in the climax of The Last film and the
Elder refuses to end the Vendetta he
says and the only way John Wick will
ever have freedom or peace now or ever
is in death which is of course
foreshadowing what happens at the end of
the film now he kills the Elder and his
return to the surface puts Winston and
Sharon in the crosshairs of the Marquee
the hotel is condemned and an hourglass
is placed on the table to start the
beginning of the countdown this
hourglass was used beautifully in the
poster and we had it being incorporated
into Wick's tie with bullets being there
instead of sand now with Winston we get
a return to be in McShane one of the
many Game of Thrones alumni that appears
in the franchise when discussing how
they originally pitched the movie Chad
said that he wanted to go with the idea
that they were creating a modern
mythology similar to George RR Martin's
work the wick Universe has its own
currency in the coins Kingdoms in the
continental and they even purposely
brought over some of the cast to add to
that idea Alfie Allen AKA Theon Greyjoy
kill John Wick's dog Natalie Tina shows
up as catiere Jerome Flynn shows up in
part three and George Giorgio showed up
as the Elder at the start of the movie
the guy who trained Sophia's dog also
train ghosts and they have lots of
carryovers from that series later on
Wick also uses a shotgun with incendiary
bullets and this is a cool tie to got
too the weapon's full name is a turn
Tactical Innovations to chorus gen 12
with drakaris of course being what the
targaryens would shout for a dragon to
light someone up
[Music]
later on we see these shells right after
the first radio scene and can catch
their cool dragon's breath with the fun
even being similar to the one that's
used in Game of Thrones all we needed
was a character to say you know nothing
John Wick but these Easter eggs are such
a good way to pay off what's inside the
franchise now when they arrive at the
Marquee Winston starts to Rattle off a
story and this is about Ned Kelly's
final words this was a real world
Australian Outlaw who shot and killed
the policemen and this happened after he
attempted to arrest his brother the bear
fled and start up a gang and this helped
them to evade the law similar to the
network that Wick uses in the end the
Gengar core and got executed as a
punishment and no we don't have that
here the Marquis said to be now a judge
jewelry and
one thing he also does is set an example
in killing Sharon who utters Kelly's
final words such is life sir now I'm
sure I don't need to say this but in
case you don't know Lance Reddick sadly
died the week before this film's release
making this moment have an extra layer
of sadness to it Lion's gate apparently
pulled out all the stops to make sure
the movie was dedicated to him at the
end and even though copies of it had
been shipped out to Cinemas they still
managed to insert the message by doing
this the Marquee shows that he's a force
to be reckoned with and throughout the
movie he talks about how people must
live by the rules however he doesn't and
he embodies the mentality one rule for
me and another for thee the Marquee also
represents the upper class and we
actually see him doing something
symbolic of this when he stirs the T
now I only learned this because of get
out and in that you might remember that
the mother Missy Armitage does it as
part of her hypnosis routine when I did
a breakdown of that I remember reading a
couple of comments talking about how
that used to be used in houses when
Masters would summon slaves this would
be to come clear the table as they'd
show that their food had finished and
they were moving on to their tea I'm not
sure if it's exactly why it's been used
here but the market controls everything
and its insertion here gets a lot of
focus so yeah I'm keeping that kind of
analysis in the video although it seems
like this might be Lance Radix final
time in the role we do know that he'll
be popping up in the ballerina starring
Anna diaris this will take place between
John Wick 3 and 4 and it's also gonna
feature a cameo from Keanu Reeves later
on we see a ballerina performing on
stage which could be a little nod to
what's coming down the line Anna will be
playing a character called Rooney and
she actually appeared in the third film
being played by unity felon anyway from
here we traveled to France namely Louis
the 14 Sun Palace known as the Sun King
Louise set this up to mirror Apollo the
Sun God who represented peace and
Tranquility when we get the establishing
shot of Paris we can also see the sun
rising over the Eiffel Tower and the sun
rising in Paris also plays in at the
ending Arcane listens closely to his
daughter's playing and we see that he
has a pocket watch that plays a tune
from it this is actually a reference to
mortimer's watch from a few dollars more
and it's not the only reference from the
dollars Trilogy the film of course
culminates in a jewel and Shad State
this was a direct nod to The Good the
Bad and the Ugly the score even lifts a
couple of notes from the Ecstasy of Gold
which was the song composed for that
seminal dual scene now Donnie Yen wants
more plays a blind martial artists and
this is similar to his role in Rogue one
when he was approached with this role
his character was originally called
Chang with him being more of a Mystic
assassin however Donnie said this was
too stereotypical and that he wanted to
use his film as a way to break the mold
does he help to reimagine character
which brings us this sunglasses wearing
slick back hair assassin that's wrapped
up in a suit I love the way he gets
given a card with his next Target and he
doesn't even read the full name he just
stops when he gets to the end such a
cool way to show the conflict in him and
we know he's only going after John in
order to protect his daughter Kane
agrees to do the job and this
conversation implies that his blindness
was something he had to take on to
retire later on before nobody goes to
meet the Marquee Kane tries to warn him
as he's well aware of just how much the
Marquee will twist any deal that they
try to do now this takes us across the
globe to the Osaka Continental which is
where we meet nobody and his emotional
support animal later on with the map in
the ransom room we see that this is
Chateau de Osaka which was a heavily
constructed Fortress now it was only on
this watch through that I realized that
all the dogs after John's puppies
survive and we have had a number of them
including this Sophia's and of course
John's here we also meet Akira and her
father the former of which pops about
the end in order to avenge her dad at a
q a mermaid Greg went too he said Keanu
outright said to Chad that Akira should
have killed Kane rather than leaving it
open-ended like what we get here however
I like the idea that they can either
continue this one day or we as an
audience can decide the fate of what
happened this obviously speaks to her
mentality and with it being around that
Vengeance Scene It could spell out where
things are going now I love the father
and daughter relationship that she and
her dad possess which Echoes a
relationship that Kane's trying to get
both could take that away from each
other and the post credit scene kinda
spells out how futile a path of
Vengeance can be the same eye for an eye
leads to both people going blind
potentially spelling out the cane may
lose his daughter too also eyes blind
you get the word Playmate you're smart
you're smart enough to check out this
channel however the blindness can also
be taken to be symbolic of the character
too as Kane blindly follows the high
table or as the others don't now nobody
sits down and he looks at his phone
which is when he this is the reward for
Wake is at 18 million this is full mil
up from the last movie and we see a hint
in his notebook to what his plan is on a
double spread page we can catch a list
of numbers going all the way up to 50
million on the right hand side is his
dream which we see being valued at 48.3
million he's got his dog there who we
know as a girl and much like Rick and
Kane he wants to retire and live with
his lady however he has to get enough
money to do this and nobody's constantly
waiting until a ransom's racked up to be
able to cover the costs of the home and
also have a bit of spare change now one
thing that he does is that he also wears
a wristwatch on the inside of his arm
which we later see Wick doing when he's
at the bottom of the steps this is
something that the military do too when
it not only stops it from cracking but
it also means that someone can read the
time without changing their aim anyway
the high tables forces arrive and
they're led by Chidi there's also
armored Warriors and the share a similar
designed to summarize now if we pause
the frame on their masks you can
actually see that they're wearing
similar ones to the Japanese demons that
used to be common in feudal Japan
they're called Ani masks and they're
Mentor represents the heads of evil
spirits they're not the only cool note
of the culture that we get either and
there's lots of things in the location
that have been purposely picked in order
to reflect this world firstly we see
these soccer Continental soldiers
getting bows and swords from fridges and
these are used throughout the battle at
ensues in Japan it's extremely difficult
to get guns and thus these weapons are
far easier to come by there's also the
fact that the armor worn in the suit is
difficult to penetrate however sharp
objects such as swords and arrows can
get through which is why we see an arrow
piercing chitty's wrist even goes
through a wall too
blunt weapons can pack a punch too when
we see Wick busting out the nunchucks
which he continues to use throughout the
fight after seeing it works to wear
people down I love how Kane uses like
doorbell sensors as well and there's so
many cool moments in these early action
scenes comes to a head with Kane and Jon
facing off against each other and man
even has to hold his breath at one point
so Kane thinks he's dead eventually he's
saved by nobody with Jon returning the
favor for his dog later on now Jon hits
the underground and we get a great use
of color throughout these scenes in
Japan they very much use the traffic
light system and the action with the
scenes where the action stops being
filmed with a red light that happens
back at the hotel on the rooftop too
before things change to Green once the
action kicks off now from here we joined
nobody meeting the Marquis and we see
gets a sort of similar deal to what Kane
likely had and if is stuck through his
hand and depending on how he gets out
shows his character anyway back in New
York we see Winston visiting charon's
grave from Latin the top phrase
translates to delivers to die with a
bottom translating to my friend this is
something Winston later touches upon
with the first phrase being similar to
another thing that's said throughout the
film Eric Voss also now has had several
of the graves here have names of the
crew on them Danny Rivera works in the
art department and Christopher
Gilbertson works on this set John ends
up returning to his Rusk Aroma family
and we watch Mr Nobody flicking through
his book on the left hand side we see
the Bowery King symbol and this actually
showed up at the start of the movie
during that opening John is greeted
through the name jordani and we learn in
Parabellum that his full name is jordani
janovic he took the latter part of the
surname for work and has been seen
as an outcast in the family however
there is a way to win his way back in
and this season going after Scott Adkins
killer Scott Adkins is someone they've
been constantly trying to get into the
franchise and this season's sharp
heavily covered in prosthetic this is
actually a nice little nod to the James
Bond franchise as in the Casino Royale
book Le shifra was an overweight poker
player that puffed on an inhaler which
we see the character doing in these
scenes John is also escorted him by a
guy who just shouts
and this was putting the film to
reference group from Guardians of the
Galaxy Chad stahlski said that he wanted
to do that as a little joke and
originally they did know what lines to
give the guy so they just penciled in I
am Klaus but upon filming it they left
it in Klaus is also played by Sven
marquard Who in real life is a bill and
bouncer his piercings in tattoos have
helped him to gain a lot of attention
and he's one of the most famous bouncers
in Europe he works at a techno nightclub
which is where we go for the next big
scene a killer calls Wick the Baba Yaga
and he also shows him the Ace of Spades
when shuffling the deck this is the car
that John later uses to cut him and it
has a lot of meaning attached to it with
it meaning death and destruction a cane
comes forth and he sips on a teacup
which looks similar to the one that the
Marquee stared at the start this
symbolically shows they're in the same
boat mentally and they're joined by Mr
Nobody Delta dead man's hand this ax is
obvious foreshadowing for what's to come
but Wick uses the hand with his hand to
turn killer into a dead man so to reach
however its name's pretty interesting
and this derives from the story of Wild
Bill Hickok Hickok was shot dead during
a poker match and at the time he was
holding this hand I think the creative
team purposely pulled from Legends like
this anytime they can because it helps
to keep the tone of this entire universe
when it kicks off I love how Kane throws
a flashbang and he's completely
unaffected due to his blindness now this
all leads to a club scene and it's
reminiscent of the ones from the first
and second movie this is reflected in
the music too with a DJ here being the
Castlevania whose music they use during
that club seen in the first film the
song we hear for this scene also comes
from that second film and it's actually
titled John Wick mode little tangent
yeah yeah as well but when I was growing
up I used to think every Club used to
have rain coming down on people whilst
they dance in slow motion like this in
actuality though most of them are trolls
and you can catch a mate Jon getting his
Wick wet from the rain outside could
have went worse with that but we kept it
PJ anyway it's a big overblown fight and
I think what they do perfectly in this
film is that they pull together lots of
different elements for this final movie
over the years the creative team have
clearly learned lots of different
techniques and have obviously scattered
several environments that they think
will make major action scenes so we have
big things like the classic club scene
the dog tearing people up like Sophia's
did in three muscle cars smacking about
and yeah it's just kind of them
employing everything they've learned now
after collecting Killer's teeth John's
brought back into the family through
Browning himself along with his
surrogate sister Katya elsewhere We join
Winston meeting back up with the Marquee
and the pair boats speak in front of
LIberty Leading the People this has a
lot of deep symbolism connected to the
movie and the pain depicts how when
people are united they can overcome
oppression this is much like how John
manages to overcome the high table and
there's several paintings here that all
connect to the story the next painting
we get to focus on is the raft of Medusa
and this is said to depict every emotion
that a human is capable of having in any
given situation Wick has really been
through the ringer and this could
represent and all the different emotions
that he's faced along the way and lastly
as the Marquee stands up and looks at
Liberty Leading the People we see
another big painting behind him this is
actually the death of sardinapolis which
has a lot of ties to the Marky himself
now to give some context to it son
Napolis was a king who had 100 prisoners
executed the Marquee has been carrying
out executions as well but it goes far
beyond that in the painting we can catch
sardinapolis wearing all white as he
lounges about whilst watching the chaos
around him and he looks completely
disinterested he also has a golden
picture beside him and both is in the
white clothing are reflected in the
Marquee the world is crumbling around
him but the villains happy to Lounge
about in his art gallery and he even has
a golden coffee machine stationed there
with him this instantly foreshadows the
fate of the Marquee and it lets us know
that he's gonna die come the end of the
film I also love how LIberty Leading the
People is placed on the opposite side
facing there so we have the ritually
unworn whilst John's represented in the
other gay gives the idea that these two
sides are facing one another and after
he's taunted he agrees to a jewel now
Winston is told that if Jon fails
daddy's gonna be executed too and we get
him saying such as live from here we go
to the Eiffel Tower and see Wick going
through another card game that will
decide his fate week wants to do it
there and then and he calls the time to
have the Jewelers being now but
unfortunately the Marquee wins and thus
it gets set to Sunrise I love the little
choices that Jon makes you though and he
clearly wants to handle things instantly
but the Marquee fires back by explaining
that even if Jon wins he'll never leave
this life the Marquee says that this is
what he is and that's all his life is as
well he rattles off about how John was
plugged from the streets as an orphan
and belittles the life he's LED and all
of his accomplishments there's no run
out there
no happy husband with a normal life it
was only John Wick however in the end
John decides his legacy is going to be
as a loving husband and all that come by
his grave and visit will see that's how
he's gonna be remembered now
interestingly the Barry King says that
he wants his to say long live the king
and this was also the phrase he said in
part three as he thought he was gonna
die now the whole thing about being a
husband is reflected in the church scene
with Wick lighting up a candle wick in
memory of his wife he doesn't think that
she can hear him but he still does it
just in case he's wrong and from here we
go to the Marquee who's faced with a
dilemma if he loses then he dies and if
he kills wake then wake becomes a martyr
this is why he sets The Hitman on Jon
and though he's a coward yeah you can
kind of understand why he's doing it and
from here Jon takes sanctuary in an
underground station which is known as
portilles often appearing in films the
station has an issu's platform that's up
kept the filmmakers so that it can be
rented out it also means they don't have
to close the station to film there and
it's been used in a lot of TV shows and
movies now over the top of this we hear
the song Liz I'm on to demon which
translates to mean lovers for a day it's
difficult to get a full translation for
the lyrics here but it talks about a
short-lived romance and being unable to
forget this I think now if I'm right
with that then I think it's been chosen
to represent Jon's marriage but let me
know in the comments below if I'm off
and I'll even let you call me a chump
either way he's helped by the Barry King
and Winston and we watch as John makes
his way across Paris whilst every Hitman
in the city comes for his head this is
but I own a call from the Eiffel Tower
during a radio scene inspired by The
Warriors the moments are almost
identical with us getting a shot of the
woman's lips as she announces the hit
through code we also get an updated
version of the song nowhere to run which
two was played in that film whilst the
Warriors made their way home Wick is
described as the man in Black and it too
influences the soundtrack with this
getting painted black when it all kicks
off he of course wears a black suit has
black hair a black tie black waist code
and later on he drives a black car this
leads to him once more carrying on the
idea he's the personification of death
or the Baba Yaga Baba Yaga
[Music]
now taking things to the Arc de Triumph
we also saw a similar scene of Mission
Impossible Fallout with both Ethan and
John driving the wrong way around the
roundabout bloody Americans but you mean
he's Canadian now this car is missing
doors with it being a simmer thing to
what happened during the opening of the
second film further ties to that movie
included being mentioned that the tarot
solves are after an audience with the
high table and this is the family Wick
went after and won and then made a truce
within two they could be wanting to form
an alliance but I'd like to think they
just want to warn them to leave Wick
alone and we see why in the next scene
with us getting what's probably the most
memorable action scene in the entire
franchise in an overhead one take we
watch as Wick works his way through a
disuse building whilst nobody stalks him
in order to up the ransom when the movie
dropped a lot of people were talking
about which game might have inspired
this but chance to helski cleared things
up and said it was Hong Kong Massacre
haven't played it but obviously this is
a genre that has deep roots in gaming
with it being used as a style and a lot
of different titles they perfectly
capture it here and it leads to one of
the best action scenes from the last 10
years saving nobody's dog he sort of
redeems the dog that he couldn't save
himself they did something similar with
Andrew and MJ in no way home and though
it's not an Easter egg to that yet it
just allows the character to right or
wrong from his past we then cut across
town to see Kane outside the Moulin
Rouge and he ends up putting a pencil in
his pocket which he later uses on chitty
Wick has been known as a man who can
kill people with a pencil and
Kane using this as a weapon could show
he's stepping into the role in this
franchise he of course wanted to get out
of it much like wig and going forward he
may take on that role before that though
we have to get to the big stair scene
and huge it out to Sarah Flores for
pointing out the deeper meaning in this
the scene here has Parallels for the
story of sisaverse who was tortured by
Hades for tricking death twice this is
something John himself has done as well
and the mid say that the punishment must
be severe for doing this first was
told that he had to roll a boulder up a
every day and every time he made it to
the top it then rolled back down again
this is reflected in John finally making
it to the top only for him to get pushed
right back down again such a crazy scene
and we feel a lot like Wick with us
being mentally exhausted by the
onslaught that we've just sat through
but Jon still has his allies and using
Kane he's able to get to the top might
be a walking with a cane pun that but
either way it leads to a jewel between
the two we get some great lines of
dialogue
off and in the end Wick wins
because he knows that the Marquis so
arrogant that he'll want to be the one
who delivers the killing blow by getting
to a point where he swaps out with Kane
John's able to lure him in by using
himself as bait and he kills the
character finally freeing himself and
also Kane Kane calls him brother
possibly showing a reverse of the Kane
and Abel story with there being an
alternate outcome Jon Dies on the steps
after saying his wife's name summing up
what his life was really about now John
has to be taken home and from here we go
to the graveyard to see him lay to rest
side by side with her Wick is no more
but the friends and people he saved will
live on potentially Kane is gonna be
going head-to-head with Akira but that's
a film for another day anyway that
closes out the movie and I hope you
enjoyed our breakdown of John Wick 4. if
you did then please click the thumbs up
button and make sure you subscribe for
in-depth long form breakdowns like this
every week really appreciate all the
support you guys have been giving us
recently I know Wiki we kind of are
going against formula and tackling
things that aren't Marvel or DC but it
means the world to me and the rest of
the team that you're still on board with
us Jared's also just dropped a big
breakdown of the Mario movie and I
genuinely think it's up there as being
one of the best videos on the channel so
if you want something else to watch then
please head over there after this make
sure you subscribe I'll see you next
time take care peace